[Music]
for me it's a way of
communion with people of sharing
I know that in my family there has
never been a meal without its bread and then
the baguette is really the symbol of the
bottom of the  sharing with friends around a
good meal the baguette is a
living heritage that accompanies us
throughout our lives when a baby is
teething separating give him a piece of
baguette to build when a child
grows up the first race that  he realizes
alone it is to buy a baguette in
the bakery for our elders purchase of
the half-baguette in the bakery and
sometimes the only daily contact
[Music]
so I am delighted and then in addition I
am I would say that I am very  happy
because it represents France well
[Music]